you got to show up number one rule of
success show up see Rambo he showed up
okay carleone showed up Die Hard boy
showed up and of course Bert Reynolds
Arnold Schwarzenegger these guys showed
up you got to show up this was given to
me thought leadership Forward Thinking
strategy for the 10th Annual Global
family office investment summary in
Dubai I showed up I spoke they gave me
this beautiful gift most people don't
show up showing up it don't mean you got
to the office you understand it doesn't
mean you came to work for me showing up
means I show up I've been showing up
since I was 25 years old man before that
I wasn't showing up I was showing off I
was acting a fool being a fool High
School I didn't show up I went to class
I never showed up my body went in the
room see showing up doesn't mean you got
there showing up means you got there
means you show up for the class you show
up for the homework means you keep
showing up to the next level and I hear
a lot of people talking about showing up
you know showing up's not everything let
me tell you something showing up is 100%
of success you can't keep showing up as
the old you you got to show up as the
new you need motivation watch a top 10
with believe Nation hey it's EV
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I struggled
to stay afloat I quit on my business
partner and the thing that kept me
motivated kept me going was studying the
stories of famous successful
entrepreneurs and in their stories it
gave me the hope the drive the ambition
the thinking that maybe I can do it too
that extra bit of belief and I still
need the stories today and I'm honored
to share them with you here as well so
today list one from one of the best
Grant Cardone and my take on his top 10
rules of success
enjoy rule number two is stop thinking
and start doing I'm more of a doer than
I am a dreamer okay I don't really dream
I don't really I mean I do I I've
written all this stuff up oh one day I'm
own up Jet and and I'm going to have a
bunch of Apartments but I wasn't
dreaming very big my apartment Target it
was like a th000 units okay I thought if
I ever had 1,000 units that I would be
that would have been the Pinnacle we own
12,000 and I'll probably buy that many
this year wow but but all this has
happened because of doing I remember
walking in a room I was in the oak
Oakbrook Marriott in Oakbrook Illinois
and I walked in a room and it was empty
and there was Chairs set up for like 200
people I said one day I'm going to speak
to a full room with 200 people sitting
in the room well we've done 35,000
person events I was there yeah so so I
never dreamed as
big as I've accomplished but I do like
I'm a doer like anything that I can do I
do um the phone calls down to grind you
know gruny kind of terrible little
things like taking out the trash okay
that is a form of doing I there's no
work that I won't do and because I know
I'll take out the trash or pick up the
boards or help the guy out or whatever
it is right because I know I can do
those things I can I can do the bigger
things too rule number three is scale
your business I made the mistake in my
career Jared Jared talked about this is
was I
got I didn't get the engagement right
first I was always engaged I was I've
been Eng I've been like I've been hungry
the whole time how many hungry in the
room I mean I'm I'm I've been hungry the
whole time I just hadn't been hungry
enough
I should have I should have been
thinking about how do I get thousands of
people working for
me how do I get millions of people
knowing me I I didn't know that that's
what I was supposed to be doing I was
too worried about selling him one
product so I could get the money because
I was brought up and we didn't have
anything so for me just to get 200 bucks
I was just doing get 200 bucks over and
over and over again I never thought
about scaling and saying hey how could I
get millions of people to go get 200
bucks and I get a little piece of it I
didn't I didn't understand the scale I
didn't understand 10x 10x was written
for me it wasn't written for
you 10x just solved some of my problems
okay I've been in business 30 years it's
only the last seven that changed my life
it wasn't the first 23 that's not
uncommon by the way okay how old is
Amazon 25 25 years old you would think
they're six or seven years
old okay when I heard they were 25 years
old I'm like I cannot believe that that
means that guy grinded that thing out
for 18 years and the engagement if
you're going to scale you're going to
you're going to get
frustrated I can't find the good people
people come here they don't really want
to work here how many how many how many
of you in the room respond to
resumés people sent you a resume I want
to work for you you call them back
they're like who are
you right their problem is your problem
everybody agree their problems are an
extension of your problems if they can't
make the if you can't make the sale
they're not going to be able to make the
sale if you don't under understand
advertising and marketing they're not
going to be able to do it correctly if
you don't understand the accounting
department they how can they possibly
understand the accounting
department I just always believe this I
can do something about
this I can do something about this
situation I there's something I can do
to solve this problem rule number four
is invest in real assets I've been
investing in real estate for 35 years we
have $4.1 billion wor the real estate uh
under control right now 25,000
apartments under management and I truly
believe with what's going on in the
banks I'm in Phoenix Arizona today
Scottdale actually and you can see all
this beautiful real estate behind me
it's just you know over the last 50
years real estate has been proven to be
an asset class that when done at the
right time at the right price with the
right debt and the right business plan
real estate has always
benefited from the craziness in the
marketplace you got Banks failing right
now or apparently failing you got money
moving from checking and savings
accounts into the big
Banks and you have office retail
apartment portfolios that are under
stress this going to be the opportunity
of your lifetime to start investing in
real assets you Bitcoin people out there
that are so interested in real estate I
know you are CU you like the cash flow
you like the
appreciation you like the depreciation
none of which you get from Bitcoin
certainly you get possible appreciation
but no cash flow no
depreciation and you don't get those big
tax write offs that come in real estate
because of what is going on in the
marketplace right now an Institutional
level this is going to be if you go back
to 2008 9 and 10 when there was the
mortgage debacle what happened with real
estate is real estate some of that real
estate got cut by 30 and 40 and 50% if
you would have bought that real estate
in 2010 you would be so wealthy today
you would be like laughing you'd be like
this is crazy I can't believe it now
remember what happened back then nobody
wanted to touch anything this is when I
made the biggest move of my lifetime I
literally went from 200 units to 12,000
units I exceeded what I thought I could
do okay because I started figuring out
how to actually put deals together what
kind of real estate will always attract
debt good debt and Equity it's not that
I in you know increased the amount of
money I had what I had I I increased the
amount of understanding I had about real
estate itself about what kind of real
estate gets good debt even when the the
banks are having problems what kind of
real estate can you buy today also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is be a great
marketer everyone talk about sales and
you are a great H you're a great with
sales but I think you are a marketing
genius I have to be honest for me you're
one of the greatest marketer right now
I'm a better Market than I am a sales
person oh my goodness and I'm a great
salesperson uh when I and I would rather
be a great better marketer than than a
salesp person why explain that because
because most people don't like sales and
and and and to become a great
salesperson like takes a lot of time and
energy okay and a almost even a certain
kind of personality which I don't think
most people
have and also even if you become a great
salesperson it's not what you want to
end up being you don't great business
people are not great the great business
people you go from a worker uh then
maybe to a salesperson okay and then a
sales manager and then a CEO of a
company or an executive and then a CEO
and then maybe one day you own the
company and then and then ultimately
you'd own multiple companies and run
corporations right th that's the
evolution well as you get up here you'll
depend on sales but somebody else is
doing them down here you're depending on
sales to make your extra that extra
hustle so people like look at this thing
I I got to become a great salesperson
but no you want to look over here you
want to start running things it doesn't
have to be your
business but you want to be running
sales team so in this Evolution uh you
have to become a great
marketer the to the degree you become a
great marketer anybody can become a
great marketer because you can hide
behind the marketing I don't have to be
front well you like to be in front right
no well do you like it it's not that I
like it it's that that I do what I have
to do to get to to get attention on the
the the offer rule number six is utilize
social media I didn't start any social
media I didn't have one follower on
social David until 2011 is that right
2000 yeah I've only been doing social
media marketing for 11 years I'm 64
years old I got introduced to social
media when I was 53 years old it's not
native or easy or or normal or natural
for me what I saw the beauty of social
media was number one it was free number
two I could bang it as much as I wanted
okay like as much as I wanted they won't
stop you no matter how much I drop on it
I can say anything I want and it's not
regulated and it's free this is perfect
for me okay you know everybody told me
to do oh there's a specific time this is
a myth there's a specific time you
should Market you know the time of day
uh number two don't Market too much
number three don't monetize Gary
vaynerchuk became famous for don't
monetize I'm I ain't got a daddy my
daddy don't own a wine shop bro I got a
monetize okay I need money I got two
kids I have to monetize so I broke all
those rules number one I Market
constantly the best time for me is right
now I add links to almost every post
that I do i' I've raised uh1 billion
dollars in cash for card own Capital
doing this and I've sold a billion
dollars worth of products over the
internet and nobody really even knows I
exist also the 15 million people that
follow me and follow whoever follows you
is not as important as the Warriors that
won't follow you that will not like you
will not comment you don't even know
they're watching many of them are
watching on Burner phones the most
qualified audience I have is not my
followers it is the Voyer audience rule
number seven is always have a plan I do
have a plan I always have a plan and
everybody should have a plan and you
need to know exactly what the plan is
you need to know also that the plan's
going to work okay like I think a lot of
people plan and they cross their fingers
most people have a plan but they really
don't know if it's going to work I know
my plans work like I I know this plan I
know what it was I've been through three
or four major recessions okay survived
all of them and I know what I have to do
each time so I've gone back and studied
what does it take to move through this
I've also studied hundreds of years of
cycles of where other families became
wealthy in these Cycles these are
moments and opportunities not problems
it's it's going to look like a problem
to you there's going to be bad news
everywhere we are in a recession now
okay here and south of here we're in a
recession and they're just telling you
we're not but we are and the recession
will get deeper it will be a very long
and ugly nasty recession but there's
something you can do about it so the
first thing is to assess all your
situations where are you with
liabilities and assets okay what's a
liability meaning like it's going to
cost you something and what's assets
that could lean into so you need to
assess those in terms of real you know
my phone's an asset right uh you know
this this is this is a partial asset
that's going to become a liability
because it's going to be an empty cup
here in a second I'm going to need fuel
I'm need water
so assess those things number two I need
to I need to get rid of the liabilities
all of them including people okay family
members brothers sisters mommies if
their liabilities they liabilities you
do not want want to drag these people
through this thing because they're going
to drag you down when you when you have
to carry this stuff with you you need to
move fast in this cycle okay and then
you'll go back and pick them up later
okay okay but you can't everybody's
going to die if you guys don't do this
plan and so I'm going to leave them for
a second so that I can go get my assets
so I can expand and create wealth for
myself so which is the third step well
number eight is manage your time wisely
looking back on the year how are you
finding time to do all you do Grant like
what does a typical day look like for
Grant Cardone like how do you prioritize
the big rocks daily well the number one
most important thing today was your
interview so I'm like we got to do that
right and um you know what really
happens for me in any given day I I
don't think about having too much to do
ever uh I don't I'd rather have too much
to do by the way than too little to do I
I do a lot better and I'm a lot happier
when I got a lot to do
so be be you know I would just suggest
everybody don't complain about having
too much to do because if you keep
complaining about it you'll have nothing
to
do and I think everybody you know has
had the experience of like a day going
by in a snap of a finger because you had
so much to do as opposed to nothing to
do and it feels like the day never ends
there's an old saying about you know if
you want something done find the busiest
person and give them the task because
the person has nothing to do will not
get it done so uh I don't really worry
about too much getting I don't think
about I got too much to do I don't
really think in terms of that but I also
don't do stuff I don't want to do you
know I was driving to the office today I
was late I was doing this interview with
oir and I was a moment late and then two
guys two grown-ups adults are driving
through our P our private parking lot
here at the office on bicycles and I
almost hit one of them and of course you
know you were response is when you you
hit somebody on a bike on your property
you want to get out and beat them up
first you know and and so the point of
that story is I I made time for this
thing that just showed up on my radar
out of nowhere wasn't on my schedule and
and I made time to be an idiot for a
moment and and got emotional so I don't
think it's real that people don't have
time you guys make time for whatever
happens number nine is dream bigger you
guys can have anything you want you got
to dream bigger man you got to do more
is simple the 2DS dream bigger do more
dream bigger do more dream bigger do
more you don't need to go back to
college you don't need to go to college
you need to pick one or two people and
let those people Mentor you you probably
need one Mentor that can help you and
the other one is a guide of what not to
do okay the lighthouse the lighthouse
you know the lighthouse some of you
probably never saw a
lighthouse you know in books you saw a
book and there was a lighthouse in a
book you don't go to the
lighthouse that's a mentor you don't
just need mentors that tell you what to
do you need to pick some mentors as the
Lighthouse of where not to
[Music]
go I I have learned more from examples
of what not to do than I have from those
who taught me what to
do see my dad my dad dad when he was 52
years old my dad was a great mentor of
mine he taught me how to work hard I
thought that worked thing down man how
many of you know how to work hard what I
don't I can work hard man I can work
hard man I can work hard but my dad
couldn't teach me how to get rich my dad
couldn't teach me how to he couldn't
teach me how to raise a $100 million
online without running an
ad using social media and do it in 100
days and by the way I'm on track to do
that right
[Music]
now okay the the next biggest thing I
will do in my life will be crowd funding
for Real Estate it'll be the biggest
thing I've ever
done and it's all about how big can I
think and how much can I do anual number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is learn to manage money you
guys want to take some notes right now
I'm going to teach you the money game
and you're going to have to learn the
money game okay I'm going to show you
how to get money to work because on this
planet you have to know how to manage
money one of the most important lessons
you're going to learn in your life right
now you don't want to add you want to
multiply this is how you get money all
right one you get it now I need to keep
it okay I didn't write save it what you
want to do is you want to multiply right
what's your name King King I like that
man okay so look King uh if when you
come back here when you come back here
let's see what's the day today 28 thank
you man man you on your game too huh he
says I get a 100 for that sure man
appreciate it what's your name thank you
Vincent my I had uncle named Vincent
good guy he always believed in me that's
how we connected me and you this guy
this guy this guy huh this guy's a
Storyteller right here huh he a little I
like that you got some Mose bro go ahead
there you go Vincent first part of this
little game right here is you don't need
to make something to get money but you
do need to get in the right
room with the right people that have
money if I didn't have any money could I
play this game with you guys no if I was
broke if I was doing the wrong stuff if
I was out you know drinking and drugging
on the weekends and I'm losing stuff and
I'm going crazy and I'm then I can't
help
you when I met a lady I called my mom I
said I met my wife
[Music]
today she's like have y'all been out yet
I said no she hates my
guts she wants nothing to do with me
okay kind of like I felt about Pete the
first time I met Pete I told Jared I
said I want nothing to do with him it's
true story Pete's like can I get five
minutes
sure sure I'll give you five minutes
might be 15 seconds boom he made an
impression with me first impression is
what's the first
impression last impression is more
important than a first impression most
of the people you meet they're going to
have a bad first impression of
you okay most of the people I meet do
not like me my wife had she did not not
like me she didn't even see
me she didn't like I was invisible to
her she couldn't remember what I had
black hair brown hair short tall she
didn't remember nothing like she's like
huh who are you I met you last night
huh yeah you know the guy the guy the
guy in the RV uh-huh so so look no
matter what you do there's going to be
people that don't know you right you're
going to be humbled Elena did not know
me did not want to know me did not want
to get to know me my mom said Grant if
she don't like you it takes two Grant it
takes two how many of your parents told
you that before it takes two you got to
have two people in a marriage and I told
my mom thank you thank you Mom thank you
and I hung up and I'm like she wrong
again it don't take two folks it takes
one person to make a relationship work
takes one person to make a sale you know
how many things I've sold in my life
where nobody wanted to buy
it okay almost probably probably 80% of
everything I've ever sold was some to
someone that didn't want to buy it the
other 20% wanted to buy something from
me last thing I'm going to say it was
his idea and our idea to get you
here you you you you got sold
this you didn't buy this you understand
that okay don't be say oh yeah I bought
it no you didn't you got sold
this okay we sold you on coming here you
this wasn't your idea you you didn't
call them and say hey I'd like to come
down to the 10x headquarters I'd like to
give you guys money spend a couple days
they're
[Music]
learning in fact uh would you guys do a
challenge put a challenge together and
sign me up for a lot of other as
well no no this was our idea to get you
here okay and that's the same thing
that's going to happen for your audience
it's not going to be them wanting to do
something with you you got to decide it
takes one person to make a sale it never
takes a buyer almost never takes the
buyer takes me to walk up and say this
is what we're doing what are you going
to do on a daily basis you got to keep
yourself busy you got to figure out some
kind of way to keep yourself busy
they're going to share with you my
team's going to share with you a little
schedule I use I'll be talking about
goal setting how to set goals how to
achieve goals how to keep your calendar
full because if your calendar is not
full and you said okay I'm going quit
doing dumb stuff and I'm I'm quit
hanging around these idiots um well the
truth is you got nothing to do and
you're going to sit around and boredom
is going to get you and you're going to
go back and you're going to start doing
the same you were doing with the same
people you were doing it with it wasn't
until I filled up my calendar with
activities and then got good at those
activities that my life actually changed
and the last thing was I had I needed to
start adding some people that could
change my life so the last three things
is you got to get better at something
keep your activities full when you're
winning when you're doing things you're
good at you will want to do it a lot you
will not burn out on things you're doing
well and the other thing is you got to
get around the right people I was
presenting in a way that appeared
confident and self
assured and that the person asking the
question actually doesn't know whether
I'm confident and self assured you don't
know see it was his perception of me not
the reality so I basically wrote this
article about five tips to handle
insecurity and I want to share them with
you right now the number one thing you
need to know about fear doubt and
insecurity is this most important thing
everyone has them everyone experiences
them it's not like oh my gosh I am so
I'm so vulnerable and so weak and so I'm
so insecure dude everybody has it I
don't care there three or four or five
people maybe over the entire history of
the world that haven't experienced fear
insecurity and doubt the rest of us are
normal okay I have it all the time I
have fear insecurity and doubt
constantly and I'm going to tell you how
exactly how I'm going to handle those in
the next four steps the first thing I
want you to know is this it's common
everybody experiences it nobody's Beyond
it it doesn't make you bad or weak okay
you don't need medication for it okay
it's normal number two fill your
calendar up a trick I play with myself
not to deal with fear is I feel my
calendar I pack it so tight I'm
literally starving fear because fear
needs time if you jam your calendar no
white space on a calendar you'll starve
fear fear lives on time okay number
three you want to use the fear look
whatever I'm scared of doing I do it as
quickly as possible okay I actually look
for things each day that I'm scared to
do the things that I don't want to do
the most the call that I don't want to
make the visit I don't want to do the
letter I don't want to send out the
email I don't those things are the first
things on my list I literally use fear
like a trampoline I want to jump into it
jump into it and hope I get some bounce
out of it fourth thing I want you to do
is start going beyond your comfort zones
you got to get outside your comfort zone
90% of people want to be comfortable I
want to feel good I want to do what feel
good that's how we end up with you know
big slurpy drinks with too much sugar in
them and you shoot drugs in your arm you
smoke weed you go out with a girl or a
guy that you you know they're no good
for you but you want to feel so good
successful people don't want to feel
good they want to feel great successful
people don't want to be comfortable they
want luxury you see the difference do
what you're uncomfortable doing the way
to get luxury is to be uncomfortable not
to seek Comfort get off the Lazy Boy a
lazy boy is for Comfort okay you got to
get into activity do the things you're
uncomfortable with go places where
you're uncomfortable visit people you
don't know yet get out of your comfort
zones the last thing I want you to do
number five is I want you to multiply
times 10 I talk about it in the 10x rule
everything you think you need to do
multiply times 10 okay you dream this
High multiply times 10 and raise it way
up 10x everything okay do it as fast as
you possibly can know that fear and
doubt are normal they're normal 10 extra
activities to where you're like bing
bing bing bing bing bing bing when
everybody else quit you're still bing
bing bing bing bing and you're still
taking action when the next next two
guys drop off you're still hitting it
okay the first two guys did 20 things
you do 200 Last Man Standing it's a rule
in the marketplace Last Man
Standing think in terms of actions not
action there is no one action that you
can do that is so unbelievable that it
would make a difference you can't tell
me one action hit one home run nobody
will pay attention to you hit a 100 home
runs and the world will pay attention
Apple computer has two 196 billion
dollars in cash today they will borrow
money tomorrow morning debt is good some
debt is good debt and there's not a
wealthy company on this uh Planet not
one wealthy company on the planet earth
that is cash free that does not use debt
I don't want to get out of debt I want
to create wealth and the way to create
wealth is through debt and the debt is
cheap the debt is under
3% I pay interest only I don't even pay
the mortgage down so basically what I'm
doing is prepaying my mortgage
massive amounts of mortgage I'm paying
down in the beginning so it stays stable
my debt stays stable and the asset goes
up in value so like like a house you see
the problem with a house and you could
shouldn't even have this comparison or
conversation because if I buy a house
for let's say the house is average house
is about $240,000 in America and I put
5% down you probably overleveraged right
there well why why would they give me
that loan and the house doesn't provide
any income back I want to check every
month I don't want to check every
quarter I want to check every month I
don't want to check 10 years from that
dude I want that paper back today I want
to sell to the Goldman Sachs and the
blackstones of the world you you you
can't start there but you can level the
game up to play there and one thing
that that has helped me whether it was
writing a book and finishing it or
starting my speaking career when I did
it 30 years old I was going door
too to businesses around America f 3
million miles go to a city I was living
in Houston at the
time in Belair Texas and I'd fly to Salt
Lake City and I'd call on business
owners I'd set a an event 2 weeks in
advance commit to the hotel fly of Salt
Lake City knew no one no one knew me I
had no name no
books uh there was no social media
and I never felt like doing I was scared
of death had no clue what I was
doing didn't know who I was calling on
don't even know how much I believed in
what I was doing like I did believe in
it but it was
like you know I didn't have any
statistics or facts or success
stories and regardless of how I felt
just like this morning regardless of how
much doubt there was or
uncertainty uh um
fear no matter who you're watching or
who you're
following whether
it's a political person
uh a rapper movie
star teacher coach parents I don't care
how much in confidence they put out how
much athlete how much confidence
or
certainty that they push out push out
like like
project they wake up there's days they
wake up and they don't feel it they
don't feel it they don't they don't want
to do it they're
uncertain uh they're feeling some low
grade depression whatever you want to
call it look I woke up like that this
morning went got up family's not here
this
weekend uh Elena's got the kids she's
teaching them how to shoot guns this
weekend and uh I'm here by myself so I'm
waking up this morning like I don't want
to work out I missed yesterday I'm not
feeling it so what do you
do what do you guys do when you don't
feel
it so this is what I do I just get a
little
closer this is what I do I get a little
closer just like I did when I was 30
years old starting my speaking career
never thought I'd be one of the top
considered one of the top two or three
speakers in the world when I was 30
years old I wanted that but I I didn't
know how I was going to get to that and
what I did was when I was having a fight
of these cities Salt Lake City Winnipeg
Saskatoon Toronto uh Vancouver Chicago
New York like I had never even been to
these places I was literally flying to
cities for the first time in my entire
career didn't know the language didn't
know the the culture didn't know how
they they those little changes in that
happened between Toronto and New York
New York and Chicago Chicago and Dallas
and Dallas and Salt Lake Salt Lake and
La those are all very very different
markets and different people and
different
thinking dude I was
terrified okay I'm doing this today to
tell you I was terrified I was so scared
most of the time that it felt like not
fear it felt like depression like I
wanted to take the FL the the the sheets
just pull them over my head so what I
did to conquer that to handle that I
literally would just get a little closer
I'd get myself a little closer to the
action like this morning I just got
close to the gym I actually went and
walk by the pool I have a pool in the
same spot that we have a gym on the
second floor here and I walked out there
and as I pass the gym cuz they're still
doing the social distancing bu here
um there was nobody in here I'm like
okay there's nobody in here it's a sign
I'm going to go in there and work out
okay so number one just try get a little
closer to the action hope that helps you
just get a little closer you don't have
to commit to doing it completely just
get closer to it I came down here
dressed uh I put that I put that on
before I left so I was ready so I got a
little closer second thing do if it
calls you do it
anyway you know I coined this phrase
years ago do it anyway a buddy of mine
about the same time I was starting my
business I was having a lot of problems
in my life I was
probably it was before I started my
business I was still in Houston Texas I
was going through tremendous tremendous
amounts of uncertainty doubt about
myself I was in a transition a career
transition I just lost a job starting my
deal and I went one year one year
without working I've never ever shared
this before one year and I did not I
mean I had a little bit of money saved
and I was going through it I didn't I
didn't literally I I looked like I was
working every day but in truth I was not
working my twin brother actually knew
that and finally confronted me and
that's what got me off my ass
but this guy told me he's like look you
wake up in the morning and no matter
what you're
feeling no matter how much you hurt if
your eyes are bleeding do it anyway and
that is stuck with me now for 30 27 28
years do it anyway no matter how it
feels do it anyway so number one get a
little closer number two do it anyway
and then number three okay regardless of
the outcome of what you did did when you
showed up to present make that phone
call uh go to the workout once you get
in there come on man put all you put all
put give it give it the best shot you
got once you're in there once you're in
there once you get going just start
moving in that direction like I just
went jumped on that thing for 3 minutes
the next thing you know I'm like hey I'm
glad I'm in here so third thing once you
get in there go all the way okay I'm
going to do that right now God bless you
hope you're doing well hope you're
finding greatness in your life struggle
through push through remember just get a
little closer two do it anyway three
once you get in there put your back into
it put your ass into it put your head
into it just get into it cuz it's
probably going to be easier once you
show up uh to do that than if you hadn't
if you get to number three and you're
having struggles remember when you leave
at least you showed up at least you gave
it something and then do that again
tomorrow what is a mindset or belief
that you
have that you feel most of the time
people disagree with you on well I think
a lot of people think that I'm a
positive person and I'm not okay this
has nothing to do with positivity or
motivation uh I I'm not I'm not like you
know Mr beat my chest I'm excited and
I'm G to I'm going to see myself through
this because I'm going to will myself
through it no I'm not going to do that
like I'm going to do something what I'm
going to do is do something I'm going to
make a call I'm going to send out an
email I'm I'm going to follow that up
I'm going to build a team that can do
the same thing like I'm going to win on
action and it doesn't mean it's it
doesn't mean I'm going to outwork you
I'm going to outr you so and I'm not
trying to outr you by the way I'm just
like I need to I need to get results in
the marketplace so I remember uh Gary
vaynerchuk was in my studio once and he
was talking about he's like I I'll
outwork you I'm like bro you I mean we
just met you don't know me I don't know
you I don't know what your work ethic is
I don't know what you do and there's no
way you can know whether you work me or
not and by the way it doesn't even
matter what matters is do we get results
MH and so what we've been successful
with this whole 10x thing is about hey I
am going to set a Target 10 times higher
than what I need for myself and I'm
going to do whatever I have to do
between now and the attainment of that
Target to to get that that is not a mind
that it is a decision but it's not some
positivity thing or enthusiasm like I
think people mistake that I think that's
what that's to answer your question
being an entrepreneur is one of the most
exciting things that you can do with
your life and the possibilities are
endless one aspect of running a business
that I get asked a lot okay over and
over every almost every seminar I go to
somebody will walk up to me and say dude
how do you handle burnout and my reply
is fast and simple I don't believe in
Burnout that's right I don't believe in
Burnout now I know if you're
experiencing that the exhaustion that is
associated with this idea of burnout
that nobody can prove by the way that
this seems impossible to you that
burnout doesn't exist but I'm telling
you listen to me burnout is not real
it's made up take a step back for just a
second while I try to sell you on this
idea and try to remember a time when you
were on fire on fire lit up excited
about being an entrepreneur see that's
gone right yeah Grant I'm burned out
that's what I'm telling you no no no no
go back to the time when you were lit up
on fire you couldn't sleep at night you
didn't need to eat okay all you needed
was the idea of a future you had for
this dream this idea this business
whatever see at that time you were goal
driven you the possibilities were
enormous they fed you you were Mission
driven see it's when the mission's
missing it's when the mission goes away
that a person starts to experience being
tapped out or burned out or exhausted at
least this is my experience look when
I'm not tapped fully into my future my
goals the potential the possibilities I
don't care what the job is whether it
was me when I was working at McDonald's
the country club I was working on a rig
down in in in in the Gulf of Mexico or
whether I was writing my first book look
when your goals aren't big enough when
you're no longer sold on your vision
your purpose your mission the symptoms
of losing interest what many call
burnout burnout are exper experienced
anytime you stop reaching for massive
success the next thing you start
settling in getting comfortable listen
settle to
settle oh I just want to settle down
dude why don't you just put a why don't
you just decide to to be to hate your
life every day see that's when you start
having problems when you start settling
that's why comfort and complacency are
the entrepreneurs worst enemy in fact I
would tell you this the comfort and
complacency are everybody's worst enemy
the only time I've ever gotten in
trouble in my life was when I was bored
complacent when I was settling who wants
average who wants average nobody wants
it okay nobody no matter where you're at
in life you don't want average but we're
surrounded by average people every day
average ideas average products average
advertising only those that have given
up on greatness would subtle for average
in the United States today we often hear
people say I just want to be comfortable
look folks that is very dangerous that
is very dangerous to consider the idea
of comfort such Comfort mentality is
what sets entrepreneurs and businesses
apart it's what makes people great is
saying I don't want to be average
consider
business consider the number of
businesses or maybe even people you know
that were once great they were on fire
they were doing great things and they
settled down into complacency they
started resting on their laurels I
recently was written by a woman this was
maybe 10 days ago she told me thank you
grant today I was fired I said what I
read your book to 10x Rule and the same
week I was fired for being super
competitive this woman was fired for
being too competitive too on fire and by
the way Grant thank you because I had
six job offers by the end of the week
see folks that's where you want to be
even if if you're at risk entrepreneurs
are often criticized for working too
hard have you been criticized lately be
criticized be obsessed over your future
be consumed by the possibilities and
people will criticize you the ambitious
should never apologize for the only
people that criticize them are the
people that have given up the ambitious
should never ever apologize because the
only people that criticize them are
those people that have given up get
excited be EXC excited stay excited
excited and never settle hey all you
guys saying I don't need this and I
don't need that I don't need this and I
don't need that I don't need that oh my
God why you got to have all that how can
you know what you want when you ain't
never done
it just keep it real man I'm sitting
here on the front of a damn 180 ft yacht
leaving Monaco telling my buddy Brandon
back there I said bro my whole
life
my whole life I have
been guilty of saying I didn't need this
or that without even knowing what this
or that
was can't telling you how many times I
said nah I don't need a yacht who needs
a yacht nobody needs a
yacht I never been on a yacht man okay
like take a Jacuzzi on this yacht while
you leave other yachts in Monaco you do
this one time and I guarantee you're
going to start thinking God damn man how
can I get me a yacht you know what I'm
saying I'm just keeping it real with you
this 10x thing makes you think big makes
you act bigger and get you around some
stuff where you're like maybe I do need
a yacht now fortunately or unfortunately
I've given this experience to my
daughter which she will never ever
forget I hope you guys or unfortunately
yeah because when you can't forget it
you can't forget it and you're like God
dang I want to go back to to that life
it's like flying private you fly private
one time and man you will hate boarding
Southwest
Airlines is fantastic man this is how
everybody should live and I'm sharing
this with you guys just so you know man
how can you know what you want when
you've never even seen it been around it
nobody's sharing it with you they're not
talking about how cool it is and good it
is cuz I know there's a whole bunch of
people in here are going to hate on me
cuz I'm
showing me and my family living on a
yacht for 2 weeks
in the south of France I know people
going to hate on me for that why though
why you hating on somebody just trying
to share a billion worth of game for
free you understand I'm just telling you
share this with somebody that's always
already tell you I don't need to be rich
I don't need to be married I don't need
to have kids I don't need to Vacation
the world I don't need a car I don't
need you know uh the
dream how would you know
if you've never had it if you've never
experienced it these are balloons for
one my my daughter
Scarlet she didn't know she needed that
but she knew she wanted it okay made me
feel good be to do it for
her so look just remember the next time
make an agreement right now the next
time you say I don't need all that just
ask yourself have you even had that do
you even know what that smells like on
Open Sea in the
Mediterranean to do a trip like this and
bring a bud say hey man I got you
bro okay to bring my kids and my wife on
a trip and not have to worry about the
money every
second I used to take vacations I
worried about the cost of it before the
trip while I was booking the trip during
the trip and definitely worried about it
after the trip get yourself in a
situation where you can do anything with
the people that you love and care for
look I'm looking at castles come on you
excited God bless be
great you guys that are just getting
started you're not going to start right
here you're going to start down there
probably in another city another town I
grew up in Lake Charles Louisiana no
money raised by a single mother I was in
debt at 25 years old first thing that I
had to do in my life was not learn a new
skill first thing I had to do to get my
life moving in the right direction was
self-development it is vital it was
vital for me that I improved myself and
I could start depending upon me I had to
show up every day with some rituals some
disciplines and start getting myself to
trust me not trust others but trust
myself to do the right thing every day
one of the things that I started doing
was beating the Sun up every morning I'm
going to beat that sun up every morning
so that I have the discipline and the
control o over my life so I knew hey
before that thing pops I'm going to pop
I'm going to get out of bed depend on
myself get up at the same time every day
and for me that time regardless of where
I was was beat that sun up no matter
where I am I'm going to beat that thing
up so it gives me a sense of control
over my own life second thing I had to
start cleaning up my life and my friends
and my environment when I was younger
between 15 and 25 I was doing crazy
stuff in my life wasting my weekends I
have the saying weekends are for the
week I was drinking fooling around with
a bunch of bad things bad people at 25
years old I cleaned it all up quit going
to those places quit hanging out with
people that did not have ethics and
discipline in their life I wanted to
build something in my life I wanted to
become someone and to do that to become
someone in the eyes of the world just
beating that sun up every morning gives
me the sense of accomplishment that I
did what I said I was going to do that I
woke up when I said I would wake up and
I start building respect for myself
start believing in myself so that I can
go out into the world and maybe maybe
today when I go into this meeting that
I'm dressed for they'll believe in me as
much as I believe in me and that'll show
up in a contract a deal maybe even some
money
dude that's not a normal State that's
lazy okay that's not normal to be
putting your head down on a table to not
be moving snap and pop do not be adding
wood to your fire look lazy as I wrote
in this recent article that was read by
almost four million people with I think
as of today 14,000 likes and just as
many dislikes even people rageful and
angry maybe you're getting like that
right now about my article that lazy is
the new entitlement look just see if
this describes you or anyone you know I
only do enough I make as little as
possible I save as little as possible I
invest as little as possible I learn as
little as possible and hey I work as
little as possible and when my five days
are over with each week I have to I must
take Saturdays and Sundays off I'm
entitled to it these are the policies of
the lazy and they are ruining our
country they're ruining anyone that
operates with them okay normal a normal
state is not lazy a lazy person is
actually educated encouraged
acknowledged and it's allowed lazy is an
allowed state in organizations so if you
see anybody in your group in your
organization in your family that's lazy
hey knock it off man it don't work you
end up with too little money not enough
love not enough work not enough
customers lazy is a failed policy and
I'm here to wake you up about it never
give up on your financial goals until
you achieve your financial goals there's
people in this room folks that are going
to be worth billions of dollars there's
a billionaire in this room right now I
guarantee you could be two or three of
them billionaires in the making right
here okay question is who's it going to
be now if somebody in this room how many
believe this if somebody in this room
made a decision I'm going to put
together a billion dollars how many
believe that's
possible everybody in the room believes
it's possible you might not think it's
possible for you but you know it's
possible which means what the money's
available would you would you do good
things with that billion dollars okay
you know that about yourself you don't
know about the guy sitting next to you
you know that about yourself so you know
somebody could do it and you know if you
did it you'd do good things with it
right so go do it man cuz the money's
out there there plenty of and I grew up
with a little uh five uh 4 foot
11 uh Italian lady that knew nothing
about money she just knew hold on clip
coupon ons save your money how many you
brought up like that Penny saved is
Penny eared Penny earned save for a see
you were brought up the same way I was
eat all your eat all your food if you
don't eat it all save it put it in the
refrigerator right some of you got you
got food in your refrigerator right now
three and four five days old you have
you have no intention eating it some of
you got you got like an eighth of a
bagel left from 5 days
ago
right now you're like it it's in there
right now you got you got you got ice
cream in your in your freezer that's
like six months old it's expired
twice it's got that much frost on it but
you got one bite
left I know it's still
good you tell your kids this too you you
pass on the same [__] to your kids
eat all your food eat all your food eat
all your food and then you wonder why we
got obesity problems in
America we live in a country that's rich
and the people have scarcity in their
minds I want to talk to you today about
success all right I want to I want to
how many Of You' like to have success in
your life okay what does that mean to
you though you're going to either go get
it or somebody else is going to go get
it there's two types of people people
that are going to get what they want and
the life they want and people that don't
life is bad for too many people good for
a bunch of people and great for this
many the biggest problem I had when I
was 15 was I was bored too much I didn't
know anything about potential I knew I
had potential but the biggest reason I
was bored is because I wasn't going
after my potential all the time I
challenge you this summer to only be
focused on hey man what's my potential
no matter how good you play your video
game no matter how good you are in
school no matter how you good you are on
the field there's another place where
coach is trying to push you to that next
level and that's where it gets exciting
you want goals that are so big so big
that every day you wake up and you're
excited and the reason I was wasn't
excited when I was your age was cuz
nobody was telling me man have some
goals man cuz if you don't have your own
goals this is what you're going to do
you're going to spend your whole life
making somebody else's dreams come true
this is what you should walk away with
today the Gap the Gap is the difference
between where you are where you sit
right now and
what and where you want to be we're
going to give everybody a copy of this
one it says I am greatness don't fight
it I'm talking to an audience who wants
to get rich just trying to really like
make something big make something big
like become like Robert Smith Rich you
know he he's the wealthiest black man in
America or Don PE my friend who's worth
a couple billion dollars in playing in
the real estate game or you know like I
I want to get to the top of the food
chain where I get to start making rules
he who has the goal makes the rules and
so I don't want a little money I don't
want a retirement account I don't want
my house paid for I don't care about any
of that stuff I want to get rich I want
to create tremendous amounts of wealth
for for the people that that my
community mhm for the PE it started off
for my handful like me my wife my kids
and then once I'm like okay I can help
more than that I can help I can I don't
mean my
neighborhood people in my neighborhood
can be helped right okay they can't be
helped they need help by the way where I
live right down the street they just
don't know they need help they're rich
but they're not wealthy they're not
helping anybody else dude they're just
helping themselves it's freaking
terrible it's a it's a life of poverty
to have your house paid for it's a
mental poverty like oh I got my house
paid for I got my two cars my kids are
going to private schools and I'm
miserable because there's no purpose ah
like I'm helping millions of people
around the
world because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
for 10 more amazing rals from Alex Heros
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there hard work will
not make you rich I get driven nuts by
the amount of gurus and influencers and
whatever who want to brag and say no one
can outwork me I'm the best in the world
so many people outwork me I still make
more money than them there has to be
something else one of the things that
grinds my gear is